his last text to me was things not
improving on oxygen need to try
something different my reply to him was
keep fighting don't let this virus
defeat you we all love you and need you
this was the last text Conan ever
received from her husband
Josh was lying in a hospital bed gasping
for air
days later
he was dead
he was the youngest one in the whole
world you know obviously you're still
grieving for that loss now yeah which
will follow will be forever my
father-in-law lost his son I've lost my
husband my daughter's lost their dad
every Father's Day every Mother's Day
every celebration
I first came to see ghanan and her
grieving young daughters Rhea and Kira
during lockdown in July 2020 three
months after jayashi's death I called
the ambulance
and he just went out
any slippers
I didn't know he's never gonna come back
Josh called covid working as a
pharmacist left exposed to the virus
without protection or indeed
garnon blames the government and wants
the covert inquiry to uncover the truth
so
um yeah here this is my dad's heart you
know it's been here almost three years
so it's faded and you can't quite see
his name but that's him Lobby's father
femi was found dead on the floor of the
family's home in April 2020. there's
always the lingering question of if he
or why would he be here and it's things
like you know when trying to diagnose
the symptoms of covert asking questions
like are your lips blue that question
doesn't apply to people like me and my
dad so you know could his life have been
saved if we had thought ahead if there's
a forethought in preparedness to
consider how are these symptoms going to
show in black skin I want Justice and I
want change there are many decisions
many actions that were made in that
building across from us in the river now
that
resulted in all of these Hearts we see
here before us I don't know if it's but
the pub and the participants are having
problems but you're
sound is not perfect
today's online hearing suffered some
technical problems and bereaved families
say they're struggling to be heard too
they can only share their stories via an
online form
the remits of this public inquiry is to
examine the government's pandemic
preparedness and to learn lessons for
the future but at its heart must be the
tens of thousands of grieving families
but they already feel like they're not
being listened to
the loss of a loved one to covid was
felt more acutely today of all days this
grief will only be made more bearable
when questions are finally answered
Ashish Joshi's Sky News in central
London